[Applauso]
allora buonasera a tutti volevo iniziare
questo intervento chiedendovi un piccolo
sforzo
pensate al luogo in cui vivete
pensate al vostro quartiere a dove avete
la vostra casa
vi piace il vostro quartiere
vi lascio un momento per riflettere
anche per creare un po di suspence
molti di voi avranno pensato magari di
no perché probabilmente non c'è
abbastanza verde probabilmente le strade
non sono in buone condizioni i
marciapiedi non si sono per niente non è
ben collegato non ci sono servizi non
c'è una sensazione di sicurezza quando
si gira per il quartiere
al contrario altri invece avranno
risposto di sì per le stesse motivazioni
ma contrarie
quindi è un quartiere con molto verde si
gira sicuri a qualsiasi ora del giorno
della notte è ben collegato ci sono i
servizi
ora tutti questi elementi che molto
probabilmente avrete usato voi
per rispondere a questa semplice domanda
che vi ho fatto sono elementi che
definiscono lo spazio pubblico ed è
quello di cui ci occupiamo di sottovuoti
però attenzione perché per noi
sottovuoti lo spazio pubblico e molto
altro
noi abbiamo iniziato a studiare nello
spazio pubblico a roma perché non
viviamo tutti lì
roma una città molto particolari e
centro si sta svuotando la popolazione
si sta spostando verso le periferie
però queste periferie molto spesso sono
quartieri dormitorio sono quartieri
ovvero dove non c'è un idea di spazio
pubblico e per spazio pubblico
intendo uno spazio che è in grado di
costruire socialità uno spazio dove fare
incontri dove si intersecano delle
azioni dove tanti cittadini possono
diventare una comunità è infatti molto
spesso in questi periferie non ci sono
spazi dove incontrarsi ci sono magari
delle aree non definite mal progettate
mal collegate che non si capisce neanche
cosa sono però ci sono magari ci
passiamo davanti tutti i giorni non ci
rendiamo conto sono come degli enormi
vuoti urbani
capirete che essendo noi sottoquote i
vuoti urbani ci interessano molto sono
il pane per i nostri denti e infatti
qual è la nostra missione qual è la
nostra idea è quella di trasformare i
vuoti urbani
in spazi pubblici in grado di generale
comunità e come lo facciamo lo facciamo
attraverso un percorso di progettazione
partecipata in cui cioè i cittadini che
ci chiamano per intervenire in una
determinata area progettano con noi lo
spazio che poi andando a vivere
molto spesso infatti se ci fate caso ci
lamentiamo della deriva individualistica
che ha presa un po la nostra società in
realtà non si analizza mai quanto lo
spazio che viviamo e come è stato
progettato influisca nel modo in cui noi
riusciamo a socializzare o possiamo
socializzare e per questo cerchiamo di
intervenire noi come ha detto durante la
presentazione e noi abbiamo lavorato in
diversi quartieri di roma il i cittadini
ci chiamano per intervenire e noi
proponiamo il nostro percorso che pur
adattandosi a seconda delle esigenze di
ogni singolo quartiere di ogni singolo
luogo in cui lo vediamo è un percorso
piuttosto standardizzato perché la
nostra idea è quella di rendere il
percorso di sotto po di un percorso
replicabile un vero metodo che si possa
applicare in diverse situazioni
quindi ci saranno persone di diverse
parti di di roma d'italia eccetera qui
del lazio e spero che questa questo
piccolo discorso che faccio possa magari
stimolati a intraprendere un percorso
del genere
il natante una parte che noi portiamo
avanti e quella dell'incontro con la
popolazione cioè noi ci inseriamo in
maniera anche piuttosto subdola
all'interno del tessuto cittadino e
questi poveri cittadini trovano il lo
stand di sottovuoti piantato nel mercato
settimanale
oppure lo troveranno durante la festa
del paese oppure si troveranno in quel
punto della strada dove ci sono c'è
molto più traffico il sabato pomeriggio
noi saremo là per incontrare la
popolazione per raccogliere informazioni
e facciamo naturalmente delle domande
molto semplici che sono un po quelle che
abbiamo fatto che vi ho fatto prima io
come il quartiere
vi piace cosa cosa funziona cosa non
funziona cosa cambiereste e da questo
grande bacino che riuscì
a contattare stando per strada lavorando
in questo modo noi abbiamo la base per
poi lavorare nelle fasi successive è
un'altra cosa importante è che questo
laboratorio fa capire alle persone che
sta succedendo qualcosa
vedendo la noi con voi mi avete viste
entrate con il ditone gigante quelle
bandiere capiscono che nel quartiere si
sta muovendo qualcosa di diverso che si
vuole fare altro e magari riusciamo a
far cadere nella testa delle persone un
seme di ragionamento che riporti poi a
fare un discorso un po più critico sullo
spazio urbano sullo spazio che in fondo
vivono tutti i giorni e quindi si
conclusa questa parte arriviamo al clou
del laboratorio tumori che il
laboratorio di progettazione
le persone vengono vengono nei nostri
incontri e progettano e questo è un
momento molto complicato perché noi del
gruppo siamo tutti architetti noi
riusciamo per noi progettare è una cosa
molto naturale
in realtà progettare lo spazio abbiamo
capito negli anni che non è così facile
per tutti e quindi abbiamo trovato degli
escamotage ad esempio
queste sono le carte di sotto fuori ogni
colore rappresenta una determinata area
e uno può scegliere un argomento che lo
interessa di più è una carta può dare
un'idea ad esempio il verde scusate la
banalità parla proprio della natura del
verde qui parla di giardino verticale
può piacere questa idea si no forse
magari ci dà un'idea migliore però è uno
stimolo a una persona che non ha mai
progettato a a proporre qualcosa
naturalmente non dovete pensare ai
laboratori che facciamo come del dl dei
momenti didattici scolastici quasi
questa situazione in cui io sono qui a
parlare e voi siete qui seduti nei
nostri laboratori non potrebbe succedere
perché i laboratori e devono essere dei
momenti conviviali durante la broker si
mangia si beve esiste insieme ognuno dal
suo contributo a seconda di quanta sia
la sua voglia e la sua possibilità di
collaborare se non siete obbligati chi
viene a laboratorio a fare per forza
qualcosa può anche contribuire con
una piccola idea con un aggiustamento di
qualcosa e questo processo in cui noi
siamo dentro dei facilitatori quindi noi
ci troviamo a gestire le dinamiche dei
gruppi dobbiamo capire come funziona il
gruppo che sta lavorando se ci sono
delle dinamiche negative e positive
dobbiamo proporre delle azioni per
contrastare le dinamiche negative
dicevo questo questo grande lavoro che
si fa poi tutti insieme e io vi invito
se dovesse mai incontrato laboratorio
progettazione di entrare e vedere quello
che si sta facendo perché sono dei
momenti veramente interessanti e
divertenti
la fine di questo percorso porta a un
progetto un progetto condiviso da tutti
i cittadini che hanno progettato hanno
discusso insieme e sono arrivati quindi
al a definire i propri bisogni propri
desideri su un determinato vuoto urbano
che vogliamo rendere spazio pubblico
però il nostro percorso non si ferma qui
per noi è importante infatti arriva da
un'altra parte da un'altra fase che è
quella dell'incontro con la pubblica
amministrazione
questo perché noi si lavoriamo in
quartieri in piccole comunità
però questi quartieri sono non sono
isole sono connesse con la città quello
che si fa in un piccolo quartiere molto
spesso ha delle conseguenze anche su
larga scala
ad esempio quando abbiamo lavorato al
pigneto e abbiamo realizzato il giardino
angelo galafati che insiste sul metro
sulla fermata della metro c nel nostro
sul nostro tar nel nostro tavolo erano
seduti il ragionamento i cittadini c'era
il municipio con gli assessori preposti
roma metropolitane m c e l'ufficio parco
giardini di roma è un insieme veramente
difficile da gestire perché e noi
dovevamo appunto gestire tutti questi
personaggi ma alla fine quello che si sa
che si ha avuto è un progetto veramente
condiviso e i cittadini hanno fatto
partecipando a questi incontri anche un
percorso formativo perché hanno capito
che i loro interessi che sono interessi
particolari che per loro sono tutto è la
cosa più importante
in realtà molto spesso devono fare i
conti con degli interessi generali
e se questi interessi generali vanno a
scontrarsi con quello che loro vogliono
bisogna trovare una mediazione
a volte forse una mediazione non c'è
però alla fine di questo percorso
sicuramente saranno più consapevoli
sicuramente capiranno di più di come
funziona la città e il incontrare una
pubblica amministrazione umanizza una
pubblica amministrazione si capisce che
non è qualcosa di lontano non è un totem
intoccabile ma proprio dialogare su su
progetti e su disegni aiuta veramente il
cittadino esso in un cittadino più
consapevole alla fine quindi qual è il
merito di questo percorso che noi
procediamo di questo che noi proponiamo
di questo metodo
prima di tutto è avere magari e
realizzato un progetto che è stato
approvato da tutti e che inevitabilmente
per i cittadini che ne usufruiranno
sarà non sarà un luogo come un altro ma
è un luogo che hanno progettato dopo di
cui avranno più cura è un luogo in cui
si riconoscono e che è simbolo della
stessa comunità è quello il lo scopo più
importante ma lo stesso laboratorio con
il suo percorso è un percorso che crea
socialità
noi abbiamo fatto sinceramente tanti
laboratori che sono finiti male per
varie ragioni che non sto qui a
rimarcare però abbiamo anche messo un
piccolo mattoncino in quella grande
costruzione che la la comunità ci siamo
quindi ritrovati con persone che magari
abitavano da parte dell'altra strada non
si conoscevano
poi il percorso non ha funzionato non
l'hanno avuto quel luogo
però forse sono un po più comunità
adesso di come non lo erano prima un po
per citare quei film una frase
abusatissima non è tanto importante il
risultato quanto il percorso in un
processo partecipativo quello lo è
assolutamente in maniera inaspettata
perché pensiamo di metterci molto di più
qui volevo salutare con un core una
frase che ha vinto importanti architetti
del novecento di carlo che dice
l'architettura con questo effetto 3d
l'architettura è così importante da non
poter essere abbandonata agli architetti
ora questo è nato
in mente una provocazione che facciamo
per carità da del lavoro agli architetti
però spero che possa esservi di stimolo
per riflettere più attentamente sullo
spazio capita intorno per non subire
passivamente quello che la città vi
offre o vi impone e magari un giorno
attivabili per migliorare lo spazio
intorno a voi quindi la vostra vita e la
vita delle persone che vi sono intorno
magari usando il metodo sottovuoti
grazie mille